supón que la economía de estados unidos
se encuentra en equilibrio a corto plazo
con una tasa actual de desempleo por
arriba de la tasa natural de desempleo
inciso a dibuja una gráfica
correctamente etiquetada de la curva de
phillips a largo plazo y la curva de
phillips a corto plazo indica el actual
punto de equilibrio p a corto plazo como
siempre los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo tomen un lápiz y una hoja de papel
para que traten de dibujar estas curvas
por su cuenta
así comprenderán mejor el concepto vamos
a resolverlos juntos en la curva de
phillips tenemos dos ejes en el eje
horizontal está la tasa de desempleo que
expresamos como porcentaje y en el eje
vertical está la tasa de inflación que
también expresamos como porcentaje
comencemos con la curva de phillips a
largo plazo la cual está fija en la tasa
natural de desempleo y es una recta
vertical la dibujamos aquí y la
etiquetamos ahora dibujemos la curva de
phillips a corto plazo esta curva
muestra la relación entre la inflación y
la tasa de desempleo altas tasas de
inflación se relacionan con bajo
desempleo y bajas tasas de inflación se
asocian con alto desempleo por lo que
esta curva se ve más o menos
la etiquetamos ahora nos piden etiquetar
el actual punto de equilibrio pero a
corto plazo muchas veces cuando se trata
del punto de equilibrio nos podemos ver
tentados a pensar que es el punto donde
se intersectan ambas curvas pero ese no
es el caso en este ejemplo el punto de
equilibrio va a estar en algún punto de
la curva de phillips a corto plazo de
hecho cada uno de los puntos de la curva
de phillips a corto plazo es un posible
punto de equilibrio si tuviéramos la
demanda agregada con respecto a la
oferta agregada entonces el punto de
equilibrio estaría en la intersección de
la demanda agregada y la curva de oferta
agregada a corto plazo pero en este caso
el punto de equilibrio puede estar en
cualquier punto de la curva de phillips
a corto plazo en el enunciado dice que
la tasa actual de desempleo está por
arriba de la tasa natural de desempleo
si la tasa natural de desempleo está
aquí entonces la tasa actual de
desempleo es mayor a ésta por lo que el
punto de equilibrio está en algún punto
de este lado de la curva de phillips a
corto plazo digamos que el punto está
aquí lo ponemos y lo etiquetamos el
inciso b dice suponiendo que no se toman
acciones políticas
de philips a corto plazo se desplazará a
la derecha arriba se desplazará a la
izquierda abajo o permanecerá sin
cambios explica de nuevo pausa en el
vídeo y traten de responder a esto por
su cuenta antes de que lo resolvamos
juntos una forma de pensar en esto es
que cuando la producción agregada
es menor que la producción de pleno
empleo habrá una tasa de desempleo mayor
y una inflación menor esto disminuye las
expectativas de la inflación es decir
que para cierta tasa de desempleo con el
paso del tiempo habrá una menor tasa de
inflación debido a la menor expectativa
de inflación por lo que en lugar de que
la tasa de inflación esté aquí podría
estar acá y así para este otro punto en
la curva de phillips a corto plazo en
lugar de que la tasa de inflación esté
aquí podría estar acá esto desplaza la
curva de phillips a la izquierda y hacia
abajo no nos piden que dibujemos esto
pero yo lo puse aquí por un momento para
que nos quede más clara esta intuición
lo que nos piden es una respuesta a la
pregunta la cual estoy escribiendo acá
esto desplaza la curva de phillips a
corto plazo a la izquierda abajo muy
bien el inciso se dice si el banco de la
reserva federal quiere disminuir el
desempleo que operación expansiva de
mercado abierto debe usar de nuevo pausa
en el vídeo y traten de responder esta
pregunta hay varias herramientas que
puede usar el banco de la reserva
para disminuir el desempleo puede
cambiar los requerimientos de la reserva
para los bancos pero en el enunciado se
refieren específicamente a las
operaciones de mercado abierto una
operación de mercado abierto típicamente
usada por el banco de la reserva federal
para disminuir el desempleo es inyectar
más dinero a la economía aumentar la
cantidad de las reservas en los bancos
para incrementar la oferta monetaria
para hacer esto van al mercado abierto y
compran bonos recordemos que cuando
compran bonos las personas que venden
esos bonos llevan esas notas de la
reserva federal y las depositan en los
bancos lo cual aumenta la reserva de los
bancos y los bancos pueden hacer más
préstamos por lo que aumentan la oferta
monetaria el inciso b dice cómo afectará
la operación de mercado abierto que
identifica este en la parte ce a los
siguientes 1 tasa de fondos federales
explica acabamos de comentar esto al
comprar bonos se incrementa la reserva
de los bancos lo que hace que disminuya
la tasa de fondos federales
recuerden que la tasa de fondos
federales es la tasa a la cual los
bancos se prestan reservas mutuamente
por lo que si hay un total de reservas
mayor entonces hay menos demanda de
préstamos porque hay una mayor oferta de
reservas el costo de pedir préstamos que
es la tasa de interés va a disminuir el
último punto es la tasa de interés real
a corto plazo esto también disminuye un
aumento en la oferta monetaria va a
disminuir las tasas de interés nominal y
real a corto plazo hay una situación en
la que quizá hay una inflación galopante
y disminuye la tasa de interés nominal
pero no afecta tanto a la tasa de
interés real pero a corto plazo podemos
decir que ambas tasas de interés nominal
y real disminuyen el último inciso dice
según tu respuesta al inciso de 2 cuál
es el efecto en el producto interno
bruto real pib a corto plazo explica
menores tasas de interés real ocasionan
un aumento en el consumo y la inversión
plantas y equipos que son más sensibles
a los intereses lo que debe incrementar
al pib
a corto plazo con eso terminamos y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo